hey everyone today i'm going to show you
a tutorial in hd hopefully um on how to
use offline gmail now you might have
heard already from all the news articles
that have been published that you can
now view your gmail inbox at any time
whether you're online or offline
so what i've done is opened up mozilla
firefox here
and we can already uh go straight to our
we can go straight to our google email
just by going to google.com
clicking gmail
and signing in now this is not by
default um offline gmail
this is
this is online gmail obviously
so
in order to enable offline gmail access
we're going to do is go to settings
and we're going to go to labs the labs
tab and we're going to enable offline
gmail it's going to have a little
unplugged from ethernet kind of icon
looking here and we hit enable now this
will work by default in google chrome
however if you don't have if you are not
using google chrome you're going to need
to do the following your internet
browser for example firefox and type in
firefox add-ons
and click on the first link which will
be add-ons.mozilla.org
and this will take you to
uh the mozilla firefox add-ons you're
going to type in and search google gears
which is what is necessary uh to install
um to install google gears so apparently
it wasn't on that site so i'll just
google search google gears
and there we go
gears.google.com is actually where you
find it and it says it is installed if
it is not installed there will be an
install a big install button here click
on it it will add it to your web browser
and now it says you can let web
applications interact with your desktop
meaning i could put a gmail icon on my
desktop or even in my communications
section of my rocket dock here
so it works with firefox 1.5 and newer
i've showed a lot of people i'm using
firefox 3.0.6 right now
also it'll work with only 32-bit windows
vista
um so internet explorer 6 or higher
so and it also works with safari which
is very sweet
so once you're done with that and you go
to your gmail obviously i'll do it again
gmail
you sign in
it'll load you go to settings
and the labs tab and enable gmail
at this point when you go back to your
inbox
this will be this will be offline gmail
and you'll have a little offline
button here
that shows that you're using the offline
version of uh google labs which is one
labs feature enabled that will be
offline gmail
now you can access your gmail inbox and
even send messages
not even connected to the internet so um
i hope this helps you guys if you find
these videos helpful or you want more
subscribe
and i will respond to whatever um
whatever tutorial ideas you can come up
with um so thanks for watching peace